Sweet baby.
Jesus.
We're back again.
Hala,
the Joe Rogan experience podcast is
brought to you by the fleshlight fuck
was that?
That's just my new shit.
I'm ready.
I'm ready for a new opening.
Allah.
God,
what's up?
What's up?
That's going to be the new thing.
Just like that.
Boys,
Joe Rogan.
Just gentle.
That's the new thing.
Brian,
go to Joe Rogan.net
and click on the link for the fleshlight
and entering the code name Brogan and
save yourself.
Fifteen percent of the number one sex
toy for men,
right?
Brian?
They were there when no one believed in
us.
They believed in me until I got one.
Fuck are you say you're not helping sell
shit.
Why are you wearing sunglasses?
You creepy bitch.
Has Michael told me to.
Oh,
well,
Michael Rupert told you to wear
sunglasses.
I would say wear sunglasses.
Maybe know something.
I would like to get those sunglasses
that Rowdy Roddy Piper had.
Yeah.
Do you imagine if they had douche bag
sunglasses?
Only sunglasses.
Holy Shit.
I was looking at those going,
I want a pair of those.
How awesome was having nice claimed.
It was amazing shit.
We're also sponsored by onnit Dotcom,
makers of Alpha brain,
the cognitive enhancing supplement,
if you're interested in these are any
alpha brain or any of the other
nootropics that we have.
We have a new moon which is a five htp
and serotonin boosting supplement.
We have this stuff called shroom tech,
which is let's get a lot of [inaudible]
in it and quarter seps mushrooms and
it's an endurance enhancing supplement
and there's another one called shroom
tech immune,
which is a fascinating one where it's a
mushroom that actually tricks your body
into thinking your body has a cold and
so it pumps up your immune system for a
fight that never takes place.
I'm not explaining it as well as it can
be explained,
but if you go to [inaudible] dot com,
that's o n n I t you can get all the
information on it.
The way we have it set up is the way
we're trying to rip people off the
least,
and by that I mean you,
when you order the first set of 30
pills,
if you ordered from us,
if you don't like it,
you get a hundred percent money back
guarantee.
You don't have to return it.
You just say,
this stuff sucks.
I'm not into it and you get all your
money back.
We want to make sure that people are not
number one,
don't feel ripped off before we even
think about making money.
And these are all things that I've
taken.
I've taken a bunch of them.
I always talk about a bill,
Roman [inaudible] neuro one a,
which is a great one.
I,
I started taking that years ago and
that's how I actually do name no name
from,
uh,
the uh,
Alice Morning Radio Show,
Sarah,
no name.
Oh yeah,
he's a good guy.
Yeah.
No name was working out with Roman.
And his turned me onto that neuro one
stuff.
And that was when I first got interested
in nootropics,
but it's a,
it's a very complex and fascinating area
of study.
And uh,
there's a,
there's,
there's debates on both sides of the
arguments that are fascinating,
but I've been using them for a long time
and I absolutely believe in them.
I can feel the difference between when
I'm not.
And when I am,
I feel like,
I think clear.
I feel like it gives me a,
a more fluid connection with my
thoughts,
if that makes any sense.
Everybody's different if it doesn't,
doesn't really hold up water for you.
Like we said,
100 percent money back guarantee.
Try it out.
Entering the code name,
Rogan and save yourself 10 percent.
All you already bitches.
Michael ropers.
Here we're,
we're,
we're fend to get to the bottom of shit.
I always wanted to say that we're
fender.
I wish I could say without irony,
the Joe Rogan experience
Joe Rogan podcast all day.
Just to clear things up.
There's a lot of people in the MMA
world.
They're saying,
hey man,
Nick Diaz no show to a match with
Braulio esteem when they were supposed
to have a Jujitsu superfight and Nick
Diaz no showed.
And they said,
are you going to take him off your,
the opening your podcast?
And I was like,
how dare you,
how dare you suggest that I would ever
take Nick Diaz off the opening of my
podcast?
That was one of the greatest moments of
my life,
sir.
I love it.
It's my,
one of my favorite parts and I don't
know why he knows,
showed.
I'm sure he had his reasons.
You know,
I don't,
I don't know what the fuck happened
behind the scenes.
I don't know who pissed him off.
You can't piss that dude off.
Alright.
If you want,
if you want that to defy,
everything has to be smooth as silk,
like the UFC.
There's no bullshit.
Everything's handled.
Everybody.
Everybody's smooth and professional and
it goes off without a hitch and he has
no problems with anybody,
but you can't be pissing that dude off.
And then expecting him to show up.
He'll just,
he'll just vanish on you.
What was the wizard some controversy
like was there a reason that he got
pissed off?
There was a weight issue.
Apparently they were supposed to fight
at,
uh,
they were supposed to weigh in at 180
pounds,
hundred and 85 pounds a day of the
match.
Like you had to weigh ins and apparently
braulio esteem.
I didn't know this.
And then he,
he weighed in in the morning,
he lost the weight,
he had to cut weight.
He had a cut like nine pounds,
so he cut the weight and he waited in
the morning and then he,
then he rehydrated and,
but the confusion of him not being on
weight or not knowing what the weight is
or when to weigh in,
it's real.
That's,
that's where it gets confusing because
it seems like it's the fault of the
organizers.
It seems like there was,
there's a big confusion as to like when
this was all supposed to go down.
And then of course with Nick Diaz,
you see,
like I said,
he can't piss them off if you piss him
off.
He's just not just show up,
you know,
and they fuck they fucked up in that
regard.
They should have had everything working
nice and smooth.
But I don't,
you know,
I,
you can't excuse it.
It was,
I would have loved to seen it,
man.
Nick is a bad motherfucker,
you know,
and for him to have the kind of
confidence to get in there with Braulio
Braulio is one of the two or three best
Jujitsu guys in the world.
I mean,
he's amazing and it is a pure grappler
mean he taps out other amazing,
pure grapplers,
very smart guy,
you know,
and you know,
it sucks for him more than anything
because,
you know,
he came over here from England for this.
This is like a big moment for him as a
representative of the best Jujitsu
that's currently available to have a
grappling match against what is a
representative of the best martial
artists to mixed martial arts.
We have available.
I mean,
Nick Diaz is in the elite of the elite,
you know,
he's right up there with the top guys in
the world as far as MMA is concerned,
as is Braulio in Jujitsu.
And so that would be so fascinating to
see them go at it.
And it sucks that it didn't work out.
I don't know why it didn't work out,
but uh,
it seems like all these guys have weight
issues,
so like that's a huge problem.
Why don't they just have like four girls
on staff?
They just have to focus on weight
issues.
They seem like they would be pros at
that.
Well they won't,
you know,
you gotta leave that shit up to a
fighter,
you know,
and this is a,
this is a different sort of situation
because there was a lot of confusion
apparently as to when they were supposed
to weigh in and different people like
Nick Diaz waiting in one day and Braulio
awaiting in the morning and the next
days there's obvious confusion.
I don't,
I don't know exactly what happened.
You would have to sit both guys down at
sort of piece the argument out,
but it sucks.
I was just trying to get an idea that
has some girls on staff just trying to
help the guy out.
Ladies and gentlemen,
Michael per tier.
And he's going to get down to the bottom
of things.
Michael Rupert's been,
I've heard that Fox magic is
particularly strong this type of month.
Fox magic been working,
so this time when the Fox magazine,
it's has been magic and all over the
place and yeah.
Yeah,
but as far as what's going on,
that's what I came down here to find
out.
I had to talk to you to figure it out.
I don't know if I have any answers for
you.
So I have a feeling.
Anything that we come out of my mouth is
pure speculation.
Good from someone who's completely
unqualified.
Well,
let's speculate at all over the place.
Just a ton of shit going on and there've
been some major changes and,
and,
and as far as my life goes,
things are changing for the good all
over the place.
I've left.
Collapsed net.
No.
Explain for the folks who are
uninitiated,
what is collapsed?
Net
collapsing network,
a collapsed net.com.
Naco lapse.net.
Uh,
it's,
it's a,
it's a company we started two years ago,
uh,
after the movie,
the duck collapse came out and it,
it's purpose was to help people to
prepare for the collapse of human
industrial civilization,
which is well underway right now.
And over the two years we've grown to
six members in 68 countries and we got
really busy.
We specialize in bringing a really
accurate news reports from all over the
world.
It gives us a real picture and telling
people what's really going on,
but also connecting them through a
directory,
a with 1600 handpicked entries that's
free the lighthouse directory for.
So the lights are just going on,
maybe it's a good idea to grow food or
maybe there's going to be more blackouts
or maybe this,
that so,
and a lot of work has been done or the
course of a couple of decades by a lot
of people.
So we bring all that data there so you
don't have to reinvent the wheel.
And then we bring a lot of great feature
writers and stuff.
So,
um,
it got to be big and we had some big
challenges.
We got a massively cyber attack this
year,
man.
They just,
Oh,
they just laid into us twice this year.
And uh,
we had some big struggles,
but the way it,
the way it all evolved and one of my
lines is like evolve or perish,
you know,
grow up or die.
And one of my big spiritual lessons now
it's about letting go.
It's not,
it's,
you know,
it's letting go.
That really gives me more options.
And so anyway,
isn't it funny that you figured it out
like later in life?
Everybody does.
Oh yeah.
Well when you're young,
it's like the big problem.
I spent,
uh,
21 years in 12 step and,
and I lived that program.
So letting go came to be,
um,
something you practice when confronted
with,
you know,
so letting go of collapse,
that turned out to be perfect.
I gave the ownership back to the,
you know,
and I'm out completely,
but now they don't have to pay my salary
and they're all on their own and they're
just so energized and they're just so on
fire.
And now I get to step back a little bit
cause I'm a tired motherfucker,
you know,
I've been at this a long time.
Do you ever put nice stories on like,
like someone found a box of kittens and
they were powering and beautiful smile.
We went home and they had a great time
day and a new episode of game of thrones
was on and we watched it and it was
awesome and they had fox news.
You.
What kind of music is that?
Fox Magic Song.
We,
we have a sound for it now.
Do you think it's possible that
civilization one arms?
Is it possible that we're just stumbling
and that will,
uh,
will balance out?
Is that possible?
Well,
absolutely.
Totally.
That's one of the reasons why I'm going
through this big change.
I mean we not only did I in two books in
the movie and everything else kinda
predict all of this stuff based upon a
model that said that that means
civilization is collapsing.
So if you see these symptoms,
there's a pretty good chance that's what
the disease is a.
But now just recently,
Fukushima is so totally out of control.
Reactor number two is so hot that any
robots they send to the reactor get
fried and so they can't get into work on
this melted core that's lying at the
bottom and,
and then they've said no machines that
can handle that.
Radiation have even been designed yet.
Oh,
okay.
That leaves a reactor to act building
for with all the raw.
That's it.
I think it's amazing that someone made
nuclear reactors in the first place.
I think it's amazing.
Yeah.
You know,
I,
I did a joke about it in my act,
but it really is fascinating that you
can build something like that,
that you can't shut off,
that someone allowed them to build
something like that where in some
unmeasurable event or the power gets
shut off and can't
get back on and time.
It's fucked forever.
There are 450 more reactors around the
Santa no phrase just had a major
breakdown.
Where's that?
That's in San Clemente on the way to San
Diego.
Really?
And they had a major.
It's down all seasons,
so you guys in Los Angeles are going to
be having some,
some humongous blackouts this summer.
Really?
And Brownouts.
Yeah,
I'm surprised.
See,
we had that on collapsed in it,
but they hide it from you in the
mainstream news here.
That's why collapsed.
That's so good at what we do.
Whoa.
So because of the.
What's wrong with the reactor?
That's the one though.
You see when you drive down the reactor
number two at Santa Ana for a right by
Camp Pendleton on that.
So it's a weird feeling to drive by and
see a nuclear reactor.
Two,
there was problems with the cooling
pipes and then I think they were
checking another reactor g,
the x rays showed some faulty piping,
but now the reactor is offline
indefinitely.
It is such a stupid fucking idea.
The idea that you can make something.
You can never shut off the the.
That you would do that.
Yeah.
That's so arrogant.
It's so incredibly arrogant because if
it fucks up and people were like,
well,
most of the time it's clean and safe.
What are you banking on?
If you look at the permanence of any
fuck up,
it would a massive amount of time it
takes before that area is not deadly to
go near.
If you look at the fuck up,
that's we're talking about thousands of
years.
Japan is dead.
Japan is mortally wounded and I've been
saying so far and it's clear.
J Japan's economy is imploding.
They,
they,
they are now a net importer.
Their debt is like a 280 percent of GDP.
And how are they getting their power
now?
Very good question.
Japan has replaced a was at a Japanese
impression by the way.
No,
I couldn't do better one if you don't do
that.
No,
no,
no.
So,
so Japan was what happened,
what?
They're running emergency diesel widely,
uh,
which is a diesel is a whole separate
issue worldwide,
but they're running a diesel.
They're burning now.
Fuel oil and coal oil,
which,
excuse me,
two grades of Oil but,
and they're importing liquefied natural
gas now that's where you build this
$450,
million dollar floating,
gigantic bomb of liquid liquified
natural gas.
And you floated across and you know,
one of those things would,
it is almost the size of an atom bomb
goes off.
This is energy desperation,
but once and when you talk about diesel,
you know,
don't buy a diesel now and here's why.
Diesel shortage all over the world in
India,
they got 30,000
generators to,
to,
to handle blackouts at the Taj Mahal
and,
and the city that's around that.
We ran that story twice on,
on collapsed net and there are so many
blackouts in India and Pakistan,
they're all burning diesel and they're
shorter coal.
I mean it's happening all around the
world right now.
But diesel's in really short supply.
What are they going to do with all these
nuclear power plants?
They can't shut them down.
Right?
There's no way you can,
you,
you can't.
Like it's not.
You can't shut it off
off.
Well,
if you combine that,
let me just take it a little bit further
ahead to where the point of all this is
going.
Okay.
Because from four different directions,
they ain't gonna shut the nuclear power
plants off.
They can't control what the got a and B,
because electricity is industrial
civilization.
Yeah,
right.
Have industrial articulates.
To put something like that in an area
where it's close to humans,
it seeds the idea that you can
completely contain that insane amount of
energy.
It's like it's so arrogant that that's
one prong of a fork.
Yeah.
Fukushima here.
The second prompt,
one of the aides,
you know what happened?
AIDS AIDS just put it out and come out
of the gate like Tyson.
No.
AIDS was killing people left and right,
but now you hardly hear about aids
anymore.
It's the best diet in Hollywood right
now.
It also generates a lot of medical and
money in the.
In the medical business.
Do you ever read like that?
Peter Duesberg stuff?
A long time.
Who he is.
He's the guy.
He's the biologist from the University
of California Berkeley,
and his claim is something along the
lines of that HIV is like a weak virus
and I may be paraphrasing here and that
when you're seeing it in people,
most likely it's because they have a
weakened immune system.
That nor a strong healthy immune system
fights off HIV fairly easily that it's
not the culprit of aids but rather a
symptom of a depleted immune system
that's from a variety of different
things and you know,
it's,
it's a crazy argument because if it's
true,
it's like how could this only this guy
be figuring that out is one biologist
and all these other guys,
they haven't noticed that.
I don't trust that tricky.
I don't trust any of the science behind,
but it's possible.
That's not possible though.
Right?
I mean it's not possible that that AIDS
is a hoax.
That's not possible.
That's not possible,
but it is definitely possible and it was
man made.
Right.
But it's a real diversity is definitely
possible that it was intentionally
released.
You really,
you think you feel like,
yeah,
I've seen this was goes way,
way back to like the nineties when I saw
these,
but these were who document showing the
first outbreak of aids and at know and
superimposed were who vaccination
programs and there was a like a perfect
match.
Wow.
Yeah.
I don't want A.
Obviously
I'm no biologist,
but I don't see how one guy could be out
there saying something like that and all
of his peers disagree.
Is that how it works?
I mean,
obviously people think that HIV causes
AIDS isn't this guy's mind.
He's like,
these people were all.
I think it's is that it was a drug abuse
and uh,
you know,
partying and he was,
that's what he was attributing to their,
uh,
their depleted states that they were
doing like crystal meth and rappers and
Emile nitrate stuff and that apparently
his immune system crushing this aim on
nitrates.
That was big in the eight seventies.
Why?
I mean,
when I was a cop,
I ran into a mill on the street.
What would they do?
Just pop it and then they smell it or
something like that.
I'll see it.
Sam Kennison had a business,
the story of the funniest dead body I
have ever seen in my life.
You want to.
Are you sending my life?
Yes.
All right.
This is,
I swear this is true.
I was working Wilshire Division and I
was a p three,
had two stripes and every Christmas cops
from one division will go cover for
another division one,
it has its Christmas party,
you know,
so we were covering for Hollywood
divisions Christmas party.
So I'm,
I'm driving up around Hollywood and we
get a call six,
eight,
42,
uh,
meet the Ra dead body,
such and such address and maybe on
Cherokee some.
So the Ra is a rescue ambulance so we
pull up and it's,
it's a three story standard,
California really bare bones,
interior courtyard,
open about balconies and it's up on the
third floor.
And so me and my partner would go
walking down and I noticed that the
paramedics are just outside the laughing
their asses off.
They're down on their knees,
they're laughing so hard.
Okay,
I don't go on.
Okay guys,
this is the dead body called right.
And at what point?
And so I go in and there's this dead guy
on the floor.
And he was a,
I would say,
young twentyish light skin African
American guy.
I'm a in a Frederick's of Hollywood
negligee.
Hello.
And,
and he was laying on the floor and kind
of Spread Eagle and I looked in,
there is a broomstick pool protruding
from,
you know,
where,
okay.
But there's only about a foot of it
protruding from,
you know,
where.
Oh God.
And,
and,
uh,
so,
the table had been pushed up against a
guy.
It was easy to figure it.
He,
I guess this will be for a man,
could buy a sex toy or something,
I don't know,
but he had been up masturbating on the
table with the broom and the purpose of
the aml was to strike it right as you
come.
Right.
But what it does is it gives you an
involuntary back spasm.
And Oh my God,
that's my aim.
Well,
nitrate story and the broomstick went up
his ass and killed him.
He looks satisfied.
Um,
what a,
what a to way to
go,
man.
Yeah.
There's been a bunch of dudes that have
gone as fixation style,
right?
That's like the nxs guy
carrying a pussy shit.
Because like a real guy would do it the
other way with the broom coming at you
from the Bristol part side.
That's,
that's the real way to know.
Look like a man.
Men.
It is West Hollywood shit.
That's how I can talk a gay samoans
handle it until you to rite of passage.
Got to use a broom the other way.
Humor was good,
but you chick.
Yeah,
that's a dumb way to die.
Do you think one of the things I heard
is like the big,
the big conspiracy that would be that if
you wanted to shame a person you would
kill them and make it look like they
died.
Masturbating like an idiot.
I mean that's like in a couple of Nwa,
so gay porns around like that would.
That would be the ultimate joke if you
found your buddy dead like alright,
he's dead.
So listen,
there's nothing I can do about that,
but what I can do is put his dick in his
hand and put a bunch of gay porns all
around them and then take pictures of
him and they'll put it online.
I got you the last,
the last one.
Come on.
That would be high.
Hilarious.
If you knew,
if you knew that guy and you loved him
and it's like the one last jokey get out
of them,
that's so fucked up.
It's so fucked up.
It's so fucked up,
but it would be hilarious whole.
You gotta have a good sense of humor.
Come on man.
That's hilarious.
All right.
I think that you remember that.
Yeah,
I remember that too.
Bitch.
That sucks.
Why do you even release that into the
photos of you out there with Dixon,
your hand and your mouth and that's the
golden rule of the Internet.
Imagine her real life conspiracy against
you nails back.
Oh No.
It's not real like a whooper went with
the sunglasses on.
That's when he's gonna.
Get deep.
It's not a weird thing like that.
That's a cool guy thing to wear your
sunglasses.
You know we're.
We're thing.
I tell you one thing,
new meme with sunglasses.
Come down and go to deal with it.
I love it.
That come from.
How did.
I love it too,
but where did it originate?
What is that from?
I don't know how to deal with it.
It's everywhere though.
I see it all.
It's all over the place.
Sunglasses dropped down,
deal with it.
It's beautiful.
But how did sunglasses to be cool?
I don't even know what that means.
What that means is whatever you know you
have issue with,
why don't you just fucking deal with it
and leave me alone.
No deal with it.
Get out of my face.
Well,
he's a cool guy.
He's got a sunglasses on.
Super Cool.
Yeah,
but why?
Why not?
How does that make you cool?
Well,
how did sunglasses become something that
makes you cool?
Right?
Because you look different.
You had your eyes or you look like.
Now you look like a fly.
You look like,
you know I've been wanting to do right
there.
Those are actually pretty dope record
hd,
but those are Oakley's,
right?
No,
they're not.
they're just.
They're a hoaxes.
That is amazing.
That's hd.
What a world we live in.
How long before you get a chip in your
eyeball that just does that?
You don't have to have seven days with
this.
Probably going to be.
We're going to be in certain shit into
our bodies.
Eventually they're going to give you
something that just works way better
like this.
All you need is this one little
microprocessor in your body and you will
never have a disease again.
It just bang.
You have like this microprocessor that
regulates your body.
They put it right in your pituitary
gland,
in your body,
like a little micro messenger,
and then that shit's going to start
getting viruses,
but every 10 years they have to give you
a brain surgery and opening up to change
the battery.
What do you think?
Yeah,
but imagine if that,
that computer,
that computer inside you,
that computer inside your fixes all the
diseases and all this shit,
and then that computer gets.
He gets a virus,
so you have to start making medicine to
help that computer.
So you put the virus,
it turns you gay minds in that all of a
sudden you just could not stop your gay
urges.
That would probably be the first thing.
Virus John Travolta had that and all
this time people were just being mean to
him and they don't know that he has a
disease.
He has a genetically designed like a
disease from like the Russians.
Maybe if you know,
if you wanted to do that and make some
like super aggressively gay.
The government has worked on this,
right?
This is not a joke.
Michael Rupert,
we're back me up.
I remember in during a rack they were.
They were trying to figure out how to
make a gay bomb.
This is not a joke they have using God
can guarantee that with all of the
hundreds and hundreds of billions of
dollars that the black ops community has
had to work with in the secret budget.
All these years,
they have tried every stupid fucking
thing in the world.
You could think of.
This idea was that they were going to be
able to spray something down like
something blows up over these guys.
It sprays all over them and it makes him
gay.
I mean they were really like looking
into the possibility that they thought
it would demoralize them.
Did they ever hear about the Greeks and
the Romans?
Some of the greatest fucking soldiers of
all time.
They were bone in each other constantly.
The Samurai's boned each other too.
There's dudes,
bone dudes back then and they were
cutting heads off every day.
There was a wild time.
You know,
you can't think that,
you know,
making these people guy is gonna.
Make a better fighters.
Well you don't want to fight for their
boyfriend now.
Fuck you up.
That's what the system does with pretty
much everything.
It takes something and it bends it.
It twists it so that you accept a way to
look at it.
That is a basic fundamental lie.
Anyway.
No,
I don't think gay or non gay has shit to
do with how good a warrior you are.
Exactly.
Yeah.
There's a lot of gay dudes that can beat
the fuck out of,
you know,
data kick once by a dyke as a cost.
What I did,
she was six,
two and she could bench like to 60 or
something.
Oh my God.
Did you underestimate her?
Did she charge you like what happened?
We just call,
it was a 4:15
fight at a bar and it was for 15
minutes.
That's a place call for disturbance,
you know,
it's 4:20
really pot.
No,
that
had nothing to do with police.
I said that's a colloquialism.
It's a native,
you know.
But as far as lapd,
you know,
I never heard of for 20th.
How did for 20 become pot?
Anybody?
It's probably a good history behind that
might be a code in some county in
northern California.
Okay.
So I'm sorry.
So for 15 comes out.
Yeah.
And go to visit it.
It's,
it's a,
it's a when we go in and you know,
and there's,
and you know,
she was fighting somebody else and I go
to step in and she and she was walk
flying across the room when you got to
be really careful because big women can
knock you the fuck out.
That's for real.
There's some big women out there that
can knock you the fuck out.
I know I checked.
It's only like 130 plus pounds.
Maybe like 1:40.
My friend Tommy Junior's girlfriend
Katie,
and she can punch a fucking hole in your
face.
Man.
This chick knows how to punch like and
she's a strong girl.
There's girls out there that can fuck
you up.
You got to be careful,
especially if they sucker punch you.
Oh,
that's terrible.
There's a great video though.
Some fucking asshole who's yelling and
screaming at this woman and she grabs
him by the collars and headbutts and
knocks him unconscious.
It was like a security camera in front
of a bar.
The guy was just being a drunk douche
bag and the girl,
the girl is bad ass man.
She was like a fucking character in a
movie.
Cool.
I mean,
she wasn't a big girl,
but she grabs him by the collar and just
fucking headbutts and right in the chin.
The dude goes out.
It was hilarious.
Yeah,
it's a beautiful video.
Have you ever seen it,
Brian?
Pull it up because it's,
it's,
um.
There's not even any audio.
It's a probably girl headbutts guy.
Kao Yeah.
Maybe.
I don't know why I'm asking you to find
that.
It's probably a billion of those.
Right?
How many,
how many videos online there about girls
headbutting a guy and knocking them out?
I could find it.
Well,
you know,
I am the only guy in the history of the
Los Angeles Police Department.
No,
this isn't it.
To have been bitten in the left testicle
in the line of duty.
Really?
Oh,
Jesus.
The only guy ever.
Was it a slow buyer?
No.
Right.
Had your hand on it and you're massaging
it and then you were.
No,
no,
no life.
Why did someone the
ball we got to call.
This wasn't a day when angel dust was on
pcp or my God,
it's the worst thing I've ever seen drug
I've ever seen in my life with.
What is the effects for the unwashed
masses?
Oh my God.
Well,
it was supposed to be.
It was designed as an elephant
tranquilizer.
That ain't the way it works in humans.
It's.
It's a.
it's a powerful hallucinogenic,
but it gives people a feeling of
superhuman strength and they have it.
They display it.
You get a real thin sheen of
perspiration and you get this glass.
He,
I looked,
just love this and so I look old and,
and,
and these guys would throw five or six
cops around,
they would pull fire,
stupid strengths things and quite
frequently they had to be shot because
there was just,
they wouldn't stop.
Um,
so a friend who got its finger bitten
off when I was on PCP,
so,
so we got to call a wheelchair sergeant
was requesting a backup.
It was just south of the station,
south of a librarian,
Venice.
They're a few blocks and we go rolling
up and here's this sergeant Tim Wright
was six foot five.
He's just backed into a corner in this
apartment and here's this little bitty
black guy,
about five foot eight like Sammy Davis
Junior,
but he's holding like a 35 inch color
console television set above his head.
Those things were heavy.
I mean,
he's right away,
you know,
it was,
it was dust and uh,
and,
and I was,
I was known as the fighter Sergeant
Sanchez Rupert getting so like five of
us went in there and you know,
it was just like one of the cartoon
Malay things.
We finally got him handcuffed and then
flex a cuffed around his ankles.
You know the plastic cups called an
ambulance,
put him on the Gurney to canvas straps
on the Gurney.
Manoevre over like torso and one over a
pfizer knees.
All right,
so we figure we got him.
We take him out to the ambulance.
Now I stand up,
but you know when you're lifting the
Gurney,
the raise it into the ambulance.
She pulled it up.
Oh No.
Oh.
So he got the canvas strap over his
legs.
Oh my God.
And everybody went back to his legs and
they went,
wow.
He went like that.
Oh my God.
He bit your ball sack.
Holy Shit.
How?
What is the recovery on something like
that?
It hurt a lot.
Nothing was damaged,
but the fear must have been horrific.
Looking down for your first time,
I must have been horrific.
Must've been.
Yeah.
So yeah,
I,
I wound up having the nickname of
inspector clouseau not,
not okay though,
you know,
I got a need and the Dick once in
Jujitsu and I didn't know how bad it was
because before I used to wear a cup,
now I wear a cup.
Smart man.
Yeah.
And I didn't realize how bad it was
until after I was done it fucking hurt
like hell.
But I figured it's just me being a bitch
because I got hit in the Dick Duke
because that's how you think.
Like it's,
it's like it's extra sensitive is my
baby.
Are you wearing a Dixie?
I wasn't wearing anything.
I was wearing a jockstrap.
I mean that was wearing clothes.
I should be wrestling.
You doing boy and my friend Einstein was
passing my guard and he slammed his knee
and he's trying to pass his knee through
my legs and he just miscalculated and
caught my dick.
And I didn't realize how bad it wasn't
till I was taking a leak after training
and blood was all over my jock strap.
My Josh trap was like filled with blood.
I was like,
oh great.
My Dick's bleeding,
this is awesome.
So like a retard.
I didn't even go to the doctor.
Instead what I did was I went to see if
I could beat off.
I'm like,
well if I could beat off,
might be good.
It can't be broken if I could beat off
and I beat off and it didn't even hurt
that much.
And when I came was like blood and come
together.
Like I had a chicken,
like a little chicken egg.
So I said,
all right,
well let's see if this heals up.
If it feels even a little bit funny
tomorrow I'm going to the doctor.
So I peed blood for like two or three
more days.
But I felt great.
So now they didn't,
didn't.
I was just checking for any inflammation
or feeling of irritation or I think,
you know,
you just heal up.
I'd like.
It's like,
would I go to the doctor if I did that
with my nose?
And I'm in the answer was no.
I would have done it with my nose 100
times.
I did drink a lot of orange juice and
tried to make orange p,
you know what I mean?
Try to make lemonade.
Yeah.
It would be like pink lemonade.
No,
but seriously that,
that's something that you probably,
you probably didn't want to get checked
out because he didn't want them to like
have to put something in your penis hole
or something like that.
No,
I didn't want to be.
I would have.
I didn't want to be a posting.
I mean if I,
if it was my ear,
I wouldn't go to the doctor.
If it was my nos,
why am I going to the doctor?
If it's my Dick,
I wouldn't want him to go to the doctor.
If it's like infected,
what are they going to do?
How are they going to fix it?
What are they to do?
They're going to put a splint on his
finger and put it into popsicle sticks
and send it back in like a wounded
soldier.
Um,
I don't,
I don't know what the fuck they would
do.
I,
it was nothing wrong with it.
It was just hurt.
You know what I mean?
Just needed to heal up,
but if it was hurt,
if it was more than that,
I would have noticed after awhile I
would have felt I was pretty sensitive.
That's a great physical metaphor for
what happens emotionally a few times in
your life when you get kicked in the
Dick.
Yeah.
You heal up.
Hopefully you heal up.
Hopefully.
Yeah.
Hopefully that's a good fit.
Physical Metaphor for that.
It's very difficult for people to accept
the idea that sometimes people don't
want to be around them.
You know?
Some people aren't meant for each other.
They're fucking personalities clash and
some people have different ideas.
It's very difficult to find someone that
you can hang with for any long period of
time.
Definitely.
We just got to learn to be nicer about
the whole process.
You know,
it's the getting kicked in the Dick
Emotionally.
Figure out how to.
Don't worry about that for you.
You know,
I had a party recently at my house,
a little kid's party and a couple
friends came over,
including a two friends that are ex's.
Uh,
their ex boyfriend,
girlfriend,
married to different people now,
but still great friends.
And it's so cool to see that when people
can connect like that and keep being can
actually really be close friends.
Like their kids play together.
They go out to dinner together,
you know,
they go on double dates together.
They were genuinely friends.
So it's,
it is possible,
but Goddamn for the most part,
most of them end up like fucking like
those air shows where they touch wings
and fucking go into the crowd and a ball
of fire.
You have to go to an air show man.
You going to an air?
Yeah.
I grew up in an air force family,
Jesus Christ.
And uh,
I've been to quite a few.
Have you ever seen a wreck like that?
No.
Thank God.
Whew.
What a.
What kind of jets did you fly?
I didn't.
My father did.
He'd never been in one.
Not,
not in a fighter jet?
No.
Did I do it?
Did a thing for the blue angels.
They would take celebrities up.
Cool.
Yeah.
We went seven and a half cheese and they
don't wear suits either.
Man.
You know,
when they do their shit,
they don't.
Most places they were like,
uh,
some sort of a compression suit that
allows you to deal with the pressure,
but they don't,
they don't wear them.
They just do it all with their body and
La.
They have to be like really,
really good shape.
Yeah.
It's just all kinds of gymnastics.
Lifting weights you have to like really
strengthen your body.
Just to deal with the g force is fucking
incredible,
man.
The feeling is it's amazing how much
pressure it is when you realize that
like going fast doesn't just,
it doesn't come freight.
Like if you want to really go that fast,
you have to move your body in a way
that's completely unaccustomed to moving
through the universe.
Like the amount of pressure that comes
from that kind of speed.
It's like monumental.
It's hard to even wrap your head around
it.
I love it,
dude.
Seven and a half.
Jesus.
Insane.
And it feels like consciousness field
literally feels like an elevator door.
You could see black on each side.
It's crazy.
It's a crazy feeling man.
But when they rack,
they were at Harvard.
I remember,
uh,
my,
my dad was a radar intercept officer and
fat,
nines and half nineties.
That's,
those are two seat interceptors.
He used to fly over the North Pole
waiting for the Russians to attack her
in the Korean War.
That was his mission and we saw a few.
Ufo Isn't some strange thing.
She needs us anyway.
Uh,
but,
uh,
so the worst and it was all air force.
So he was in the late seventies,
early eighties.
The,
the thunderbirds,
the.
We're doing a of a five for formation
loop,
ground loop and something went off in
all five.
Flew straight into the ground and that
was like,
that was just go,
oh my God.
Oh my God.
Holy Shit.
That's crazy.
It's fail.
Yeah.
What happened?
How the fuck does that happen?
Something I'm not gonna say it wasn't a
combination of pilot error and
mechanical failure because everybody
follows the lead.
Oh my God.
Nobody else is paying any attention to
anything except the lead.
Oh my God.
That's so crazy.
That is so fucking crazy.
Yeah.
That's hard to even think about.
That's one of those things.
It's hard to wrap your head around,
you know,
what that must've been like to be a part
of and know that it's happening.
Like right before the fucking plane hits
the ground.
Yeah.
They didn't even know.
They might have had a microsecond to
know.
The guy that took me on the blue angels
flight was a bad motherfucker.
I wish I could remember his name and I
have it at home.
It's on a signed photo,
but we went through these canyons and we
were going.
It was so fast.
It was ridiculous and we're only like a
couple hundred feet off the ground and
it just.
When you realize what those things can
do and think about if you were on
the ground and one of those
motherfuckers was looking for you,
holy Shit.
God Damn,
that's scary.
One of those fighter jets looking for
you while you're on the ground would
have to be one of the most frightening
things.
Well,
they fly too fast.
I mean this is.
This is where I have some expertise
because of the life I've led hanging
with some green beanie guys and you
know,
they can't see anything.
They fly too fast,
too fast.
So you need helicopters.
Yeah.
Well you,
you would want to,
uh,
Hilo where the flir for.
We're looking at infrared radar for
night.
That's a third gen night vision where,
where you can pick out the heat moving
very easily.
Could they use like a blimp or something
just floated up above the sky and get a
big view of that shit.
You,
they really aren't there.
Do that little micro copters and they
got all the money.
It's like Jack Nicholson in Batman.
Where did they get all the toys?
Just that's what they did.
Why did they feel like they have to
control things so much?
Why is that?
Because it has to be so many.
So much resources spent on this aspect
of society.
It's the infinite growth of monetary
paradigm,
but it's also a people who who have
control,
if you will.
We have someone call them the powers
that be.
I'm getting a call them the powers that
were because they're failing
monumentally,
uh,
but they must maintain control.
Otherwise all of the crimes that have
been committed for eons will come
starkly clear to a lot of people all at
once.
Uh,
that's like the awakening of the
hundredth monkey.
Like,
Holy Shit,
we are human beings really have been
farmed.
What does that expression,
the weakened over the hungry 100th
monkey because I've heard it more than
once now.
That was in,
that was in the Daca,
collapsing it after the Second World War
and they were playing with the atom
bombs.
They wanted to see how long it would
take to repopulate an island.
So they went back to this island and a
four or five years after and then they
introduced trees and they got things
grow and then they brought in like
10,000
monkeys to see how they would survive a.
There was enough for everything,
but the,
the coconuts were slightly radioactive
on the husks.
So the safe way to eat the coconut was
to wash it in the stream and they taught
like 10 monkeys to wash the coconut.
And so they and then other monkeys look,
and then pretty soon there's 15 and then
47 and then a 200,
or excuse me,
you know,
88.
But when they reached the hundredth
monkey,
all 10,000
got it all at once.
Everybody is.
Oh yeah.
Okay.
So then they all started washing the
coconut.
Yeah.
And,
and that's,
uh,
that's a parable about,
you didn't tell me the story the last
time you were here.
What did you know?
No,
it was in the movie.
That's what it was.
Okay.
Um,
but,
uh,
so that's,
a,
that's a
parable about a radical shift in
consciousness.
And right now a radical shift in human
consciousness is the only thing that can
possibly save us.
And there's a part of me for all of the
stuff that I've done bringing the bad
news.
Uh,
which was my mission.
That was my duty for like 30 years.
It was like to warn.
And now this,
now the Fox medicine spiritual message
says they've had all the warnings
they're going to get.
But now I'm also very aware that this
change of consciousness is happening and
I'm seeing enormously encouraging signs
of that.
One day we won't have to think about how
we suddenly try to get governments to be
honest or you know,
one day,
listen,
this government right now,
one day is going to be embarrassing.
It's going to be embarrassed.
They're going to look back.
It is.
I agree.
All of them have been.
We're going to look back on this time
with shame because the people that are
running this country,
that's very small percentage of the
people,
they're not going to be able to maintain
it.
It's just too.
There's too much access to information
these days.
It's not the same animal as it was when
this whole monster was created.
If you look,
Joe,
I'm anywhere in the world.
Every government is failing.
There is not a government anywhere in
the world that's succeeding because the
way they're set up is ridiculous.
The whole thing is ridiculous and after
a while,
people just,
they can't take the inequity of it.
They just.
The people snap everywhere.
This is even this one.
The best one.
There is,
without a doubt,
I think Americans,
the best setup there is.
I love it here.
It's the greatest country in the world,
but God damn it could be better.
It can be better by a million fold.
It could easily be better.
I don't think America can be fixed.
That doesn't mean that I'm on American.
What I mean is I think the United States
of America as it's operating now is not
fixable.
It's set up on a bullshit financial
system.
That's a real big part of it.
It's utterly corrupt.
I'm Thomas Jefferson here.
I'm saying this.
Thomas Jefferson said you need a
revolution every generation.
Have you ever thought about just moving
to Hawaii saying,
fuck you.
You ever thought about doing that?
No.
No,
I,
uh,
I spent four months in Venezuela.
That was a,
an unusual story.
But no,
I'm,
I'm where I'm at.
I'm up in northern California.
That's where I'm staying.
Staying.
Yeah.
So to asteroid.
I'm planting my ass in there.
They're going to have to come with a
bulldozer and take me out of there.
You're out there making it happen while
you sure that this is all gonna fall
apart though it is falling apart.
What are the.
What is the possibility that something
can happen that can pull us out of the
fire?
Something that's gonna.
Keep us from the only laminate to the
mountain.
The only thing that can keep us from
slamming into the mountain is for the
human race collectively to see it
slamming itself into the mountain and
decided to do differently.
It's got to be a change of
consciousness.
This is not going to be a message
written in a letter put out
in a broadcast,
put out.
Everybody's got to get it.
I personally think the Internet itself
is very psychedelic and the fact that
it's responsible for a massive expansion
of human consciousness,
not from a drug form,
but from an information for them.
The fact that you're the access to
information is so spectacular and so the
whole viral aspect of it.
I think that that human beings right
now,
what was a very rare time where we're in
a balancing act right now,
but I think the information that we're
getting from the Internet is expanding
consciousness as much almost as a drug
would,
you know,
as an influx of you look back,
unlike,
you know,
19 between like 1994 and now what a
massive change in our society has come
about because of youtube and twitter and
facebook and the interconnectedness of
society.
The massive extent of it is so much
different than it was.
The evolution of en via the net are
amazing.
Amazing,
but I think that that's going to
influence the way the government works.
I think it's going to influence who are
the people that are in positions of
power.
I think it's slowly going to root out
the old.
The old system that's in place was all
these fuckers were around before the
Internet.
All of them except Obama,
the Obama,
you know,
he should have been just a little bit.
He's a little bit older than me,
so he was a grown man while the internet
came out and you should have maybe maybe
it was too late for him to maybe maybe
it's one more generation after this
where they they realize you can't
fucking lie anymore because there's new
technology that lists or read thoughts
and then everything has to be done
transparent.
I don't think it's going to take
anywhere near that long,
this,
this old system is going to collapse
because it will be satisfied with
nothing less.
It's seeking its own death.
It's doing everything to kill itself
intellectually.
Anything running this world right now is
being defeated.
Do you think that's because the current
people are greedy and they're just
looking out for themselves and trying to
just score short term and just get out
because that's where the money's at.
Michael Rupert,
I think that they're trying as good.
Right?
That was good that they're trying to do
anything they can to hold on to what
power and what information they have
because they do not want the power or
the information that they have to be
shared and it's a.
it's a total desperation move and
they're going to fail if I was a doctor
for the world and I looked at this
problem and I was like,
hmm,
I see we got.
This is a bunch of cunts that haven't
done mushrooms and they're running
things.
That's what it,
that you have a bunch of old greedy fuck
heads that are,
that are just unsightly,
delicately inclined.
They've never had consciousness
expanding experiences.
They don't know the beauty and the love
that you get from a psychedelic
experience with friends where you,
you realize how much of the way you
behave and live and interact with
people.
It's just an insecurity.
It's just,
it's just stupidity.
It's nonsense.
It's not sure.
I'm not sure that happen,
but
it would cure it all.
Baby Lord.
Seven billion doses of DMT.
Yeah.
I think,
uh,
I think it would kill the ego.
I mean,
that's,
that's really what what you have today
or you go to kill the ego.
That's the dilemma.
That's the issue that you.
And that's why I'm writing a third book
now because,
well,
that's why everybody hates a chicken
hawk.
You know,
the idea of someone who wants to send
people into battle that's never been in
battle themselves,
but of course you're so confident and so
of course you're so aggressive about
this.
This is not yours to risk.
You know,
it's the,
the,
the ego has no.
You don't understand what a war is.
If maybe if you had been there,
you would have a completely different
sort of appreciation.
Yeah.
You wouldn't be so callous and it
wouldn't be such an easy option.
I've,
I've come to a darker conclusion than
that,
Joe.
And,
and,
and that is that these people literally
look at us as cattle,
expendable cattle that have been farmed
for Millennia.
This is real or well,
this is,
this is what it really is,
is all about human beings are born and
bred to be slaves and consumers to
generate wealth.
And that's the way it's always been.
Roughly since there was,
since we started doing money,
this one
or who are they?
Is it a vein or is it just a series of
shit choices that have left us in a
situation where people are copying
things.
You know,
we,
there was a thing we talked about really
recently on this show about the Salem
witch trials,
the Salem witch trials.
There was a woman who wrote a paper for
a history class.
It sort of solved one of the major
puzzles of the Salem witchcraft trials
and it was that there was an ergot
poisoning of food.
It was causing people to have a LSD type
effects and that they thought that this
was responsible for the original
murders,
but then they kept it up as a tradition
for years later.
Then it became a hysteria and then even
though people weren't even ergot
poisoning would actually become a
learned behavior.
And I think that in situations like
where you have greedy business people
and they set up corporations and there's
patterns of learned behavior that come
about from the way these corporations
interact with their consumers and the
environment that they have there,
their businesses set up in and that this
momentum gets carried away to a point
where the greed and the bottom line
supersedes human nature at supersedes.
The idea that you are a group of people
and you know in the documentary the
corporation,
they went over this,
that a corporation tends to act as a
sociopath.
Well,
I think we just have to make everyone
aware of the accountability of their
actions in that situation and remove
that,
remove that as a design.
Remove that,
that,
that diffusion of responsibility that
you can get by being a part of a big
group that does something really fucked
up,
but you don't feel responsible for it
because you're just one piece.
Well,
from,
from my spiritual perspective,
and let me just add that my DNA,
my dmt journey,
my,
my cans just went crazy.
What'd you do to my headphones?
What happened?
My cans
just went.
I went into an echo chamber.
It's cool.
You're right.
Your sound right now.
I don't hear anything.
Fox match.
That's for the folks listening on
itunes.
There was a photo of him.
Michael with his dog and he's got the
glasses on.
This dog is a Fox face.
That's brilliant.
That's very funny.
That's awesome.
DMT trip on the message.
Have that.
What is his name?
DMT teacher empty under who?
DMT underscore trip.
Thank you buddy.
I don't know if he made it,
but whatever.
What was I talking about?
Fox Magic.
Somehow or another it came up.
What were we talking about?
Oh,
a DMT.
Uh,
I approached that very spiritual.
I,
I do medicine journeys as,
as part of my spiritual practice.
And it's very important for me that I
always approach a medicine with a clear
intent and it's always to seek and learn
something better.
Yeah,
you better respect it.
Yeah.
You have to respect psychedelic trips.
If you think you're,
you're the shit and you can handle it,
it'll fuck it.
Throw.
You know,
there's a lot of people.
I spent days preparing to do that.
Yeah.
Well there's a lot of people that will
listen to the man if you left hammers
around.
Lots of people are going to use to build
houses.
Some people are going to break car
windows with them so people are just
going to hit trees.
Friends of ours.
It's like,
it's like they,
they go do and go to the UFC and I'm
like,
man,
that's crazy.
Like you don't want to.
Do you really want that?
That's not do if you would.
Joey ideas?
I would say yes.
I would say if you didn't do it,
what are you a pussy.
If you're a real hunter s Thompson Fan,
you're a fan of Hunter Thompson and Joey
Diaz wants to do mushrooms with you at
the UFC to fucking mushrooms.
So what are you crazy?
I of course that's not respecting the
spiritual trip.
Fuck it isn't what a grand opportunity
that isn't life to do mushrooms at the
UFC with Joey Diaz.
God dammit.
That's the best seat in the house.
I thought I had the best seat in the
house as a commentator.
I don't.
The best seat in the house is to do to
get them to eat mushrooms next to Joey
Diaz.
UFC because you know,
funny Joey Diaz will be on mushrooms.
It will make me chuckle fast.
Everyone would just be howling laughing
and you'd get to watch the UFC at the
same time.
It sounds like the greatest day on earth
you might have a panic attack.
I think that it's just too many people I
like.
I like being with nature.
If I'm going to go on any kind of
spiritual trip,
I went nature.
I won't be able to.
Are you talking about spiritual trips
while you're smoking a cigarette?
It is a spiritual trip.
It's just not as.
It's a shitty one.
Tobacco trip.
It is.
If you're a native.
Yeah,
sure.
About tobacco holds a strong ritual for.
Well,
it also is a part of the IOWASCA ritual
for some reason,
like a lot of Iowasca arrows.
I think that's how they say them.
They,
they,
they blow tobacco,
smoke on people.
It's part of the whole thing.
Yeah.
I mean nicotine or tobacco in of itself
and even nicotine is proven to have some
really positive health effects and there
was something about nicotine that
actually is good for your heart
and now some like it's not nicotine.
That's really the problem.
It's like caffeine.
Caffeine is not bad.
If you have just a little bit.
If you're fucking crazy,
you're drinking red bulls all day and
check this.
I'm,
I'm 61.
Okay.
I smoke.
Everybody knows that.
Okay.
My,
I just had a physical resting blood
pressure was 60 or a blood
pulse rate was 60.
That's incredible.
Resting.
That's really good.
Blood pressure was 1:20
oversell in really good shape.
Do you do a lot of exercise?
It's pretty low.
I eat really,
really,
really good and,
and then I exercise as much weed,
whack in two and a half acres now.
So that's,
that's work.
That is work,
you know.
And I mean,
you know George Foreman when he was
training for fights used to chop wood so
well known fact.
It's like real work.
Real work is hard work you.
No Shit that gets you in shape now.
That's a pretty low resting heart rate
though.
Yeah.
So you know,
what I'm saying is I'm,
I'm just real simple
by an to all the propaganda I'm sold
about everything because the way the
people that run this world operate is
they do it 90 percent truth and 10
percent bullshit.
And because you're not trained to
separate the bullshit,
the bullshit winds upstair in you.
One of my favorite articles that came
out during the time that the Patriot Act
was administered was a,
it was on CNN.
They were talking about how the CIA has
announced that it's going to leak fake
new stories in order to send terrorists
in the wrong direction.
And I,
I remember reading that and I was like,
wow,
that's like game over.
Like they just came out and said,
we're going to lie to you.
That was,
that was right at the same time that a
CNN,
uh,
let it be known that the Department of
Defense was permanently stationing
military intelligence personnel in the
CNN newsroom.
Whoa.
I screamed about that from the
wilderness.
That was my newsletter for eight years.
We had some great people there.
We were just kicking Bush Cheney in the
balls every chance we could get.
Why was it from the Wilderness?
Why'd you call it from the Wilderness?
Because for my personal story I had been
trying to expose.
Cei was bringing drugs into the country
for like 18 years and nobody would
listen to me.
Then Gary Webb stories broken.
I confronted the CIA director at Locke
High School.
And the game changed a little bit.
Uh,
so I started ftw,
uh,
like a year and a half after I
confronted John Deutch and uh,
I was a voice crying in the wilderness,
but I was the guy from the wilderness
that nobody had listened to and,
and then,
you know,
and so that came to stand for,
uh,
over the course of my career.
Many hundreds of people in organizations
who were all,
uh,
voices in the wilderness.
Nobody was listening to.
And Damn,
we got it all right.
You know.
And uh,
there's some just amazing people I've
met along the way.
It's an interesting name.
I remember when I,
when I first found out about it,
I was like,
what the fuck is,
what's that from the wilderness?
It was like,
it sounds very unabomber ask funnel,
you know,
like you're out there.
This was before hearing it,
the disease society out in the distance.
Yeah,
no,
this,
this was just a,
hey,
you know,
pay it.
W we were pretty successful.
We got to have 60 members of Congress
and we broke the Pat Tillman,
the whole,
the whole cover up with Pat Tillman was,
was a seven part series.
We did ftw and uh,
uh,
that's one of the good things now for me
about giving collapsed that over to the
employees.
I didn't get a chance to do that with a
few because our computers were smashed
in the Tillman series.
I mean police falsified reports,
a leaked to editors who were having sex
with my children and for defrauding them
and they really threw everything,
including the kitchen sink at me up.
And I actually talked to editors that.
What was,
what was that?
Uh,
there was,
uh,
my computers were smashed and part five
of the tilghman series.
That's right when we were nailing Donald
Rumsfeld and he was eventually forced to
resign.
He was forced to resign because of the
Pat Tillman.
And so yeah,
that was what did it.
Yeah.
He just resigned real suddenly.
Right.
When Henry Waxman's a committee on
governmental affairs was getting ready
to call him.
What was the issue that he had created?
He,
first of all,
if you wanted to have a bad guy and like
a Batman movie,
that was like a bad government guy that
was actually evil,
would not Donald Rumsfeld will be the
fucking perfect guy.
Dick Cheney's,
right.
He's right up there too.
Both of them.
But.
So what,
what exactly took place?
Well,
uh,
we eventually nailed that.
The series was being written by Stan
Goff,
who was my military affairs editor at
from the Wilderness stands for retired
master sergeant from US Army Special
Forces Delta stand taught at West Point.
Stan is just one of the most amazing
writers and human beings are really cool
people I've ever met in my whole life
and a brilliant guy.
And a pat tillman's mom.
Danny,
uh,
contacted me trying to get in touch with
stamp,
uh,
and,
and I immediately said we'd publish
anything.
And I,
I drove down to the Tillman House in,
uh,
south of the bay and a copied overnight
2000,
200 pages of army records that she had
been given all redacted,
you know,
all blacked out and pages and stuff.
But they were in files and sections.
And all this stuff.
So I returned the papers and drove back
up to my offices and I flew stand golf
into Ashland,
Oregon,
and we stand.
Did most of the work,
but absolutely because Stan knew at all.
So he decoded the documents and figured
out who was who and what was what and
where it was,
where,
uh,
I caught some things that help but stand
wrote the seven part series a that
proved that a stand that uh,
pat had been killed by friendly fire at
close range,
uh,
and the Silver Star awarded him was,
I think that that was probably the most
offensive thing.
The,
for many in the,
in,
in the military was that that silver
star was fake,
not just destroys the value of the
silver star.
Uh,
and uh,
so
we broke that story and uh,
and this is similar to what they mean,
it's been the Jessica Lynch story that
changed that story around to apparently
any story that gets released,
any big story gets doctored up
favorably.
And so this one was an unfortunate
incident.
It wasn't a murder,
right?
No one's claiming it wasn't murder.
Oh No,
I,
I think people claim it's Samaritan.
I think Danny believes that it's
possible that her son was murdered.
I think she said so.
She said so to me,
um,
I,
it could not have been premeditated,
uh,
because it was in a full bar situation
there.
It was not really combat,
it wasn't exaggerated stage play in some
respects.
Uh,
there had been some incoming fire,
but it was like three,
400 yards away,
take a couple of mortgage,
fired a couple rounds and ran away and,
and,
and hear a whole lot of rangers.
It just start opening up on a lot of
everything all at once.
This is basically the way that played a
and a but pat,
Pat Tillman's last words,
when he stood up before he took a three
round burst from a sauce squad automatic
weapon right here.
I mean it just took his head off where
I'm pat fucking tillman
and that's not disputed that that's
fully in the record.
Oh,
who was the guy that pulled the trigger?
It was a sergeant in his cereal.
What was he just,
was he on edge or was he trying to kill
him?
I can only speculate here.
I'm a,
if you add a space that was a really
smart guy and he was honorable.
He had seen that,
that
the war was all fucked up.
It was all lies that,
you know,
and he was disheartened.
I hear he was a pro football star,
right.
And,
and uh,
I quit the NFL,
a huge move to join the army to defend
his country because he thinks that,
you know,
everything that you see in the movies is
how it works out and you're supposed to
rise up when your country gets attacked.
As,
as a patriotic American.
He wanted to do his part.
Well let me just continue with that a
little bit.
And he kept a diary and so there would
be naturally be fear that he would come
back,
rejoined the NFL and start bad and the
government.
But that
didn't really factor into it that that
could have been controlled in many other
ways than that.
Pat Hung around frequently with special
forces and,
and that's,
that's kind of a no,
no.
In theater,
because one group does what they do and,
and anyway,
that's just the way it works.
Um,
and I,
I think he was something of a
grandstander,
uh,
you know,
a bit.
Um,
and uh,
so I think he was making a lot of noise
and he was pissing some people off and
he was complaining about how fucked up
things were on.
Somebody might've put it to him.
Yeah.
And,
and,
uh,
I think he became a ranger before he
became a soldier and maybe only Rangers
would understand that or SF would
understand that.
But uh,
uh,
it's,
it's a,
it's a totally Shakespearean tragedy.
I mean,
it's just like so fucked up all the way
around for everybody.
Yeah.
Did you ever hear the eulogy the brother
gave?
It's pretty intense too.
Do you think it was something to that
extent of Pat?
You know,
pat sat and Heaven,
Pat's fucking dead.
Something along those lines.
You know,
he's an atheist or something.
I'm glad you didn't know him because
then he would have like lipstick all
over him and they had
pictures.
I don't even want to joke about this.
I don't even want to joke about it
unfortunately.
But your joke about it,
I almost,
I came close to,
but you joke about it with me.
No matter if you've got blown off your
head got blown off.
I wouldn't put a big deck like damn.
So try to suck it a smaller Dick Bitch.
That'd be the last thing I would do for
you.
But it's like an American hero,
right?
The whole thing was sad.
It was very,
it was,
um,
you know,
it was sad that he,
he,
you know,
he chose to jump in and uh,
it was sad that it wasn't what he
thought.
The truth is is that everything about
those wars,
the,
the post nine slash 11 wars,
everything about those wars is fucked
up.
And when,
when,
when you start off with everything on
the,
on the floor of your building on that
fucked up the war that takes place on
top of that field can't be anything but
more compoundedly fucked up.
How do you have a just war when you go
into it with no ulterior motives?
Analyze.
Yeah.
It's amazing that this is not like a
fucking army of people in jail right now
know it's,
it's amazing.
It's amazing that they can get away with
that level of corruption and not be
accountable,
but they do in the world,
in ones and Zeros,
you know,
the Cartesian world,
measurable matter.
And of course we know there's such a
thing as spirit.
There are things other than matter,
but they operate as if everything is
matter.
That's what we gotta do,
man.
We're going to bring them into the
light.
That's what we got to do.
That's the solution to all of it.
It's not as.
I'm not even fight them.
It's like they are us.
They're just us in the worst case
scenario and the worst possible position
doing the wrong thing.
Exactly.
That we are at one of the most ethical
times in human history,
of course,
perhaps all of human history.
And I really believe that what I said in
the movie,
uh,
is happening,
that,
that our species is being forced to
choose
to evolve or portrait parish to grow up
or fucking die.
Well,
it's obvious when you look at like what
we're doing as far as like and fish out
of the ocean and depleting resources and
polluting things.
It's like we're.
We're certainly not doing it in a
sustainable way right now and now I
don't.
I don't think it's impossible if,
if,
if we kept the population exactly.
How is it?
It is right now.
It might even be possible to run the
world the way it is and use the
resources,
but know what might be possible do as we
move along.
If it's not how we doing it right now
we,
we are overextended,
but we're doing it right.
No,
no,
no.
We are about.
Everything is imploding right now,
but right now we're doing fine right
now.
We have electricity.
We the food.
Okay.
It's not everybody.
This is.
This is the ego bomb because this is
where I have the hardest trouble getting
through to people,
but because they'll say,
whoa,
how long do we have?
When is it going to happen?
Right.
And subconsciously,
all they're really saying is how long
before it fucks with me.
Yeah.
How long before I'm uncomfortable
exactly by like here we are,
but you know,
that's why collapsed net exists because
we bear witness to the fact that,
uh,
all over Pakistan,
cities are having blackouts.
That by the way was very authentic.
Pakistan,
the blackouts lasting weeks at a time.
Same in Mindanao,
uh,
India,
major power blackouts.
A civilization is collapsing all around
the world.
And just because people choose not to
hold it in their consciousness don't
mean it ain't going on.
So you,
you recognize it as an inescapable trend
that only a shift in consciousness can
alter.
So if the shift of consciousness
occurred,
how would that alter what would,
what would be the correct thing to do if
the,
the human population was brought into
the light and everybody's sort of
figured it out and said,
hey,
we have to act responsibly and stopped
being a bunch of greedy.
Cons,
what would we do?
I think it would all spring from a
fundamental
overriding awareness.
Not a conviction,
belief,
just awareness,
you know,
you're living it,
uh,
of
the oneness of everything,
of the connectedness of everything.
Uh,
oh,
that's the place where you start
and
once you do that,
among other things,
you overcome the pairs of opposites,
good,
bad,
rich,
poor fat,
thin,
whatever,
you know,
this world of duality.
Um,
and uh,
and I hit,
there's some amazing work being done in
quantum physics that is totally bearing
this out.
Uh,
there's some amazing research,
uh,
amit
go twomey is,
uh,
is a,
a quantum physicist and great book out
by David Wilcock and other stuff that,
a lot of stuff that I kind of became
aware of along the way.
So there's,
I think the awareness of that.
Once it,
once it comes or at flowers in the
species and pray,
pray,
God's got a spirit.
It does.
Soon.
Uh,
we just won't.
We will just automatically stopped doing
all the stuff that we're doing that's
turning this planet into a living hell.
Come on.
The Gulf of Mexico is totally destroyed.
They got shrimp with our guts hanging
out in one eye and that eye in their ass
and crabs with half.
I shell,
I mean,
we've been running the photos of this
on,
you know,
on collapsed net.
So it climatologically there's,
there are a plumes,
two,
one,
two kilometers across 20,
30 of them have methane venting directly
up from Tundra in Siberia.
I mean it's like methane is 20 times
more powerful greenhouse gas than co
two.
This mess is out of control.
It's going to come crashing down.
The only thing,
because by calculation I had a guest on
my radio show.
Great Guy.
I'm a professor from Arizona State and
so I'm having a brain fart on his name.
It'll come up in a minute.
Thank you very much.
Um,
but climatological that there's an
incredible study that says you have to
stop all economic activity now or else
all of the everything dies irreversibly
as a result of temperature rise as it's
hard science.
So you know,
on all these fronts,
with all that stuff happening,
I just stood back,
reason I went,
this train wreck cannot be prevented at
this level of consciousness.
The only thing that can save us now
literally is a miracle,
right?
A miracle,
a revolution of human consciousness.
But if that does happen,
if there's revelations,
revolution,
whatever you want,
would want to call it.
If that did happen,
what would we do?
How would we fix everything?
That just seems to me that the,
the,
the we have to ship things.
Okay.
We have to move,
we have to manufacture shit and we have
to move it around places because people
need stuff.
You know,
you got to get food to supermarkets,
you gotta,
you gotTa keep growing it.
You got to keep it can keep a good cycle
going on.
So you've got to burn something.
You gotta use something's got to run
those engines.
And then on top of that you have to have
at least public transportation.
And then people were going to want to
have cars.
Okay,
how are you going to get all this shit?
Just drives you crazy thinking about
that doughnut.
Well,
it's amazing that we got so out of hand
and we got out as a society.
We're like,
um,
it's like someone who was just at a
college and you gave them an unlimited
mastercard and you don't have to pay for
the first year.
And they just fucking went bananas,
you know,
they went bananas to the point where
it's completely unsustainable and then
you realize you have this debt of
the way you're living.
It's just so disproportionate resources.
Here's the ultimate kicker to all of us.
There are not enough resources in the
world to pay off the debt that has been
printed since 2008.
All the bailouts or debt.
So all the resources in the world like
as far as all the gold,
all the diamonds,
all the oil.
How about iron and copper and food.
But energy is the first resource because
without energy you can't use anything
else.
So that's amazing.
So how is that possible that we have an
economy that's not based on an entirely
what,
what?
Anything can be worth,
that that just shows you how completely
full of Shit.
The whole idea of the economy is,
if they're the whole,
all the resources of the world and you
owe more than that.
Someone got fucked.
Someone.
Someone,
someone fucked you out of the whole
world.
Plus.
Yes.
Think about that.
Think about how strong the fuckery is in
this economy.
That is so bad that literally we owe
more than there is value in anything in
the world to pay off.
It costs more to make a penny than a
penny's worth the same thing.
I mean it seriously,
but here's,
here's,
here's the catch to all of that is
founded,
founded on a premise of infinite growth.
Wow.
Infinite growth on a finite planet.
It is not possible with finite
resources.
Yeah.
Have you ever read black gold
stranglehold?
Do you know the premise behind that?
Oh,
that was.
Who was that?
Was that your room course?
No,
that was sinful book.
Wasn't really.
I had it on my disinfect show.
Really?
Yeah.
So it was a book that was,
it was still completely ridiculous.
I was like,
well,
how do you,
how is that guy that knows it?
Uh,
the,
the premise was that goal that oil was,
I'm not a byproduct of fossil fuels or a
biotic.
Yeah.
That,
it was a process of the.
It was like literally the blood of the
earth.
Earth has an endlessly filled,
creamy nougat center that will satisfy
your every desire for as long as you're
Kinky,
as should crave it.
What dirty evil vampire cons people are.
We just suck the oil out of the earth
until it's dead.
That's what we're doing.
We're running our entire crazy business
on the blood of the earth.
We're like the craziest.
Exactly what it is to.
Yeah,
it is the blood of the earth.
Soil is life.
All we're doing is burning ancient
sunlight that was stored in light.
It's all solar energy in one form or
another on this planet.
It's crazy when you really stop and
think about it like that.
It is God.
It's amazing.
It's amazing when you really think about
what it is.
Why do you think they're natives?
Call it father sky,
because they were dumb.
They didn't shit.
They didn't know.
Oh yes they did.
They didn't even have fucking horses,
man.
We had given them horses settled down.
Fucking magic.
That might be all fake.
Listen man,
those are the people that came across
the bering strait.
And it was proven recently actually when
this Mormon tried
to,
uh,
tried to flex because he in the Mormon
Book of Mormon,
whatever the fuck that nonsense that
Joseph Smith character wrote when he was
14 years old,
that everybody followed along with a,
it was said that they believe that the
American Indian was actually the lost
tribe of Israel and that he was going to
prove it with a genetic test.
So he ran a DNA sequence on an American
Indian.
And most,
most of it is a actually Asian.
Most American Indians are actually.
They came down from the street hockey.
Joe was 18 sixties running a DNA test.
What?
No,
no,
no.
Recently ran a DNA test on American
Indians and find out the origin because
if they were Israelis,
he could like see this is the lost tribe
of Israel.
If there were some medic and he could,
I guess they could find that out,
but it was not.
It was the most likely that they were
Asian religions or business.
And I really think overall Christianity
had the best business plan.
That's what it boils down to a.
But what's happening now is people are
also beginning to understand that part
of this great awakening is that many of
us are returning to wisdom that existed
before the word religion even existed.
It was.
It was the knowledge of the ancients
living in direct connection with this
planet and everything on it.
You can adjust the tension.
You can absolutely learn from other
people's revelations that are written
down and recorded,
but the moment that people start
attaching gods to them,
and sorry that you were talking about a
bunch of Shit,
you don't really know what the fuck
you're talking about.
If you're a human being,
then you really don't know what you're
saying.
You're saying you're saying a bunch of
nonsense.
You know?
Either you learned something or you
didn't,
but they.
When you,
when you start thinking about things
like Mormons are scientologists or
anything where it's like just even a
whiff of crazy.
It's like,
how do you address that?
Had Dog allow it to happen is.
I'll tell Ya,
I've never met nicer folks than Mormons.
Some of the nicest people I know are
Mormons.
They have a great sense of community in
the Mormon Church.
Um,
I've actually been to services before
because I had friends that were Mormon.
I've been to a mormon funeral before.
They are very polite and nice people,
and if you wanted to find like a
religion,
he said,
well,
here's a religion.
It looks like it.
It enhances family life a little bit.
They do a lot of things together.
There's probably a lot of benefits to it
when you get past the fact that it's
based on some nonsense fairy tale
written by a young con man.
Mormons are also very,
very,
very smart in that they have focused on
food storage and food preparation for a
long time and that is the single most
critical factor for who's going to make
it and who's not in.
You Go,
dude.
You do.
You have to bring everyone back to the
end of the world.
Doom and gloom.
Well,
no.
We need to take.
You might have a wake up.
It was the last time you were at
Disneyland,
man.
Oh my God.
No,
it works today.
But you should go to Disneyland before,
like the fucking planet of the apes
stocks.
Collapse of civilization happens and
you're out there mad max in it and
you're fucking bio diesel truck and you
pass by the Disneyland when Anaheim is a
fucking ghost town and you have to get
in the car because the zombies are
common.
This sounds like a movie.
There's a movie woody house and would
be.
It's like,
what was that?
Zombieland.
Zombieland deuce.
Zombie land.
Duke's go.
Disney land brings him Fox.
Yeah.
Just fuck up some zombies at Disneyland.
Actually.
You know,
if there were places to party,
I,
I can think of a couple more.
I'd rather party assets.
Beautiful.
Disneyland.
It's fun.
It's great.
Did you end up going the other day?
Oh,
it was awesome.
I want to go.
There you go during the week day,
man.
It's great to use the APP.
Did you know it was really.
The lines were easy.
Well,
I go on little kid rides.
A totally different experience.
I'm not waiting for space mountain.
I remember waiting like 10 minutes to go
in the submarine the submarine.
And I liked the teacups that just kids
love tea kills her fun.
Those are fun.
Disneyland.
It's fun when you,
when they're your kids.
It's really an amazing thing that
happens when you have kids is that you
get the actual joy of them having joy.
It's really strange.
Like I used to see kids having fun and
not go,
oh,
that kid looks like he's having fun.
That looks awesome.
And it would make me feel good.
But it doesn't make you feel good.
Like you're a little kid experiencing
the happiness when you have a kid and
they're happy,
like jumping around and laughing and
having a good time.
You actually experienced that feeling.
It's like you live through it.
It's amazing.
You know what I don't like?
I don't like when kids have that thing
where they,
out of nowhere they just start grabbing
on your leg and like,
like,
like holding onto you and you're like a
random stranger kid.
You're at the garden or something like
that.
They're just grabbing it.
Yeah,
it's uncomfortable.
You're like,
I'm good.
You're do I start documenting like,
I don't want to be happened.
Nothing happened.
But Buddy,
yeah,
I will.
I don't want to pick your kid up and
have you weird out to some dude.
Just picked up your kid.
You'd be like,
hey man,
what are you doing with the baby?
Got that.
What a commentary on this world.
Well,
go automatically there.
It's like there's so many of us,
there's so many of us that the,
the amazing spectrum of human behavior,
it's,
there are possibilities.
You can run into people that are
completely crazy.
We all have in our day,
you know,
in the world of martial arts and
fighters and I run into some fucking
crazy people.
I'm sure your world takes that to the
next level times 10.
You know,
being a police officer in Los Angeles
and all this shit that you've seen.
I mean,
your,
your like Douchebag to nice people ratio
that you saw in your line of duty is.
Oh yeah,
it's fucking hard to.
Hard to keep a,
a cheerful profile.
Well,
that's one of the,
there's a jesuit mystic named Anthony de
Mello and he has a great line.
He says there comes a point in your life
when your options are to either go stark
raving insane,
commit suicide or become a mystic.
Hmm.
I want to be a master.
Well,
you are a man.
Really?
I think I would want to be like the
silver surfer dude.
I want to silver surfer reboot if you
could.
Yeah.
Fuck.
I want it to be like digital,
like style,
like
where it's like when he's flying or like
digital.
I enjoyed the first silver surfer.
That's good movie.
Yeah.
W reboot that.
Who owns that together?
Company don't silvers.
Well it was,
it wasn't a part of the avengers or.
No,
not the avengers rather.
Um,
fantastic for no testing.
One thing was where was,
where was the last silver surfer?
I want to say it was one of the
fantastic four movies singing x men x
men.
It was that.
Yeah,
it is Eczema.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
It's been one of the exponent.
Yeah.
[inaudible] got to find out which one
fantastic brick dude in that stretchy
dude that was like silver surfer wasn't
involved in that.
I don't think so because I think silver
surfer was straight.
What isn't he?
I think he's.
I think he's looking at God or
something.
Wow.
Remember the story behind it?
Thought you were going to come on for a
serious discussion about the end of the
world.
This is like a download.
I'm just checking what's going on in the
universe around here and.
Well,
I just think it's possible that a lot of
people.
Okay,
here's,
here's a.
here's a funny thing.
When you're worried about the end of the
world,
you worried about the collapse of
civilization and in the meanwhile people
see a smoking cigarettes and they go,
if you want to stay healthy and happy,
why are you poisoning yourself?
Deal with it.
That will now be a meme that will now be
a meme that was spread spread across the
Internet.
So beautiful.
But I mean,
I was talking with my friend Duncan
about this.
We were talking about people were like
looking for chem trails while they're
smoking cigarettes.
They're fucking poison me from this guy.
Um,
you're poisoning yourself too.
Doesn't matter.
Enjoy it.
I've,
I am what I am.
At 61 years of age,
after all the shit that I've done in my
life and I'm alive and healthy,
I got wounds and scars and don't.
We don't go there and it's like
cigarettes.
If civilization falls apart,
do you have a stockpile of cigarettes?
Are you just going to quit?
I don't have a huge stockpile.
All rationale quit.
If I have to.
Wow.
Would that be the biggest thing that you
would miss about civilization?
What would it be?
The Internet.
Oh,
I would not.
I'm tired of the Internet,
Dude.
I.
I needed prior to the Internet.
I need to be getting there.
I'm getting tired at the end,
so we'll both.
You guys are pussies.
You should go get.
Go in a room together and make fuck
you're talking about.
I love the Internet.
It's the greatest thing that human
nature is ever invented.
Well,
that's where you're clicking right now,
but see,
I'm what I'm saying.
I'm starting to click in a different
direction.
I'm starting to click.
I'm moving more to live in my spiritual,
my inner life and,
and building my own life boat because he
needed a night on the town hookers and
that's what you need in a limo and a,
and an Asian driver knows how to weave
through traffic.
No,
I think I'd rather just have a big party
at my house or we cook a leg of lamb and
all sit around and eat it.
Sounds awesome.
Smoke a little herb.
Eat organic food and then then bigfoot
makes it to the board.
Anybody who wants to go off and make
love to you,
just do it.
Don't you live up in big foot country?
There's bigfoot sightings up there.
Say Northern California.
I don't think so.
Have you ever been to a swinger party?
Uh,
kind of.
Yes.
And kind of know.
It was like,
yeah,
I know going in,
but then it turned into one time I broke
out in the middle of it.
Yeah.
Wow.
I want to go to wine.
Yeah.
You think that trying to fuck,
you know,
I wouldn't do that of a man.
What's the word?
What's the hang up man?
Putting your butt,
man.
No Man,
fuck your wife.
I'm like,
let's get out of here.
Is that a broomstick?
Trying to have stone Burbank's though.
I got a feeling that broomstick stories
kind of spread.
I would imagine it would get on the
Internet and that's a ridiculous way to
die.
Oh,
well I have another one.
Okay,
that's pretty good.
I get a call to a dead body and in the
ambulance suicide in a,
in a,
in,
in the jungle and Wilshire Division.
Then,
and we roll up and here's,
here's this dead guy in an easy chair.
It's Kinda like this.
And I walk up and look in risks are
slashed blood out.
But then I look up and his throat's also
slashed.
Think about that.
His wife was saying she committed
suicide.
How you cannot slash your own flesh or
residency depressed and can't do it.
She went to jail for murder.
He had been beaten or for,
you know,
for so many years and she just lost it
one day and uh,
you know,
8 million tragic stories,
but he was definitely not a suicide.
Why can't you do that?
Why can't you slash your throat and then
cut your own risks?
Can you do risk and then throw it out
too fast.
You'll bleed out too fast.
Whoa.
They make the movies.
Make it seem like you could like
actually play a piano song before you
die.
She must have been a bad ass bitch
though.
She could pull that off.
Cut a guy's wrist and his neck.
It's amazing.
And people get tired of kicking their
ass.
It's amazing what raged can do.
You know,
it's fucking assholes out there.
We have whatever we have stopped that
Michael Rupert is.
That's my number one goal in life
lately.
So figuring out how to diminish the
amount of assholes in the world.
Hey,
I get off the Internet.
The Internet has the secret.
I became a cop trying to do that.
And,
and you know,
clearly that's a losing battle.
That was your motivation to become
himself,
to try to make a difference.
Absolutely.
Do you remember when you started to
realize that the system was almost like
unfixable?
Uh,
well,
you,
you require that in stages.
I mean,
I pulled worm out of a can,
CIA bringing drugs into the country.
I said,
this is wrong.
As soon as I get this to the right
people's attention,
they'll stop it immediately.
Wrong.
Of course.
That was before Iran Contra.
And uh,
and so that worm turned out to be all of
human industrial civilization.
It,
it turned out to be the whole economic
paradigm.
It turned out to be.
Everything was crooked.
Everything was a lie.
Everything was manipulated.
I had a CIA friend recently who I was
talking to,
a former CIA guy and,
and he had been in a meeting,
uh,
that was the first briefing of Bill
Casey as a DCI under Ronald Reagan,
director of Central Intelligence.
Bill Casey wore the glasses,
start,
ran around contract.
He had been a stock broker before he
became CIA director.
There's a clue.
And Bill Casey took a US domestic
cocaine consumption from 60 metric tons
in 1979 to 600 metric tons.
And that money went to Wall Street.
So,
uh,
Casey had his first briefing as DCI and
he said,
gentlemen,
we will know that everything that,
that we are successful,
when everything that the American people
believe is true is false.
Jesus Christ,
I've been around,
you know,
I kept good notes.
That's why I'm alive.
I took really good notes and I left a
good solid record.
You know,
so you think you're alive because you've
said too much already and there's
nothing they could do about it.
And it's like,
it's,
it's out there.
No big deal.
Let him live.
I also think I'm alive because spirit
wants me alive.
The spirit I've had,
I've had spirit intervened so many times
in my life.
And that's part of what the story is now
that I have to tell in my next book
because there is something powerful and,
and I think wonderful a foot here.
And all I can do is tell the truth about
it,
but it would be dishonest of me as a
journalist to leave that out of the work
that I've already done.
When you exposed all this,
when you expose the CIA,
when you stepped in front of the,
uh,
what was the man's a designation?
The guy that you,
uh,
that
and John John Deutch,
he was DCI,
director of Central Intelligence,
appointed by Bill Clinton.
That was an incredibly courageous thing
to do on camera,
you know,
to step in and,
and not just say that you were a former
Los Angeles police,
narcotics officers that when you were,
that it caught the CIA doing this,
but you named operations,
you know,
mean you,
you,
you gave out information.
It wasn't just,
it wasn't just a,
a blank slate.
I had a lot of shit.
Yeah.
That must be the worst fucking case
scenario for the,
the creepy industrialists.
Constant run the world.
Some dude who wants to be a superhero.
Some dude who wants to save the world.
So now I'm just pissed off.
I hear him just fucking pissed off for
a good reason.
And you don't,
you don't want to recognize this,
but that's a hero move.
Okay.
When a guy does that and stands in front
of a motherfucker like that and you say
what you said,
it's Brian,
do you have that clip?
Hold up.
Pull that clip up.
Because for people who don't know who
haven't heard this or seen this,
this is pretty intense stuff,
man.
Gonna make me smoke.
Yeah,
go ahead and smoke.
Well it was,
it's a,
it's a courageous move,
man.
I mean it,
it takes a note that I know you couldn't
help but your courageous,
you can't help but you just,
it's what I wanted to get at was.
Sorry,
what was,
what was your thought process and what
was it like when you finally got that
information now when it came out of your
mouth,
what was the,
what was it,
what did that feel like when that whole
courtroom was cheering?
Oh,
that wasn't,
you knew that he was the high school
auditorium.
There were 12 slash 12 and uh,
it was high.
I was,
it was unbelievably high.
It was like super peak awareness.
You know,
how it is when you know how it is.
And,
and it was like,
whoa.
It was like one of my favorite maxims is
don't shoot unless you've got a
headshot,
and I had John Deutch and a headshot and
I pulled the fucking trigger and that
cost him his appointment as secretary of
defense.
Really?
Yeah,
and because he clowned him like that.
Oh,
we didn't have anything like a sound
bite is wringing his hands and he looked
like the typical evil white dude's
that's exploiting.
Yeah.
That's it.
Back back it up so people could see it
as soon as November 15th,
1996 as a former Los Angeles police.
Narcotics.